the departing ministers party paid
tribute to him but for hans-peter
friedrich in the CSU there's little to
celebrate friedrich could even face
criminal charges he shirt off you know
song does he followed he'd let me add
here that I fully stand behind what
hans-peter Friedrich said and that he
acted in the best interests of the
governing coalition in business I
consider the way the SPD handled this
entire thing inexplicable and that I
rejected in the strongest possible way
clearly the chefs in Sochi wiseness in
October as interior minister Friedrich
passed information to SPD head Sigmar
Gabriel about a police probe involving
SPD lawmaker Sebastian adati Gabrielle
rejects accusations that either he or
others had then tipped off a dirty villa
has done neither mr. steinmeier nor mr.
Obermann nor myself informed adati I
haven't even met with mr. adati since
then one steers clear of such matters
ending laws and V adati has been named
in connection with an international
probe into child porn prosecutors
suspect that he may have been forewarned
authorities have conducted a number of
raids on his home and offices miss
Mullens off we were also quite stunned
to find out that apparently a broad
spectrum of law enforcement authorities
had already been dealing with the adati
case and issuing evaluations before the
justice system ever gained possession of
the files in questions breaking stuff
have become it's the first scandal to
rock Chancellor Angela Merkel's new
government and clearly it has yet to run
its course